what color underwear are you wearing me
do you actually want to know
sure I'll show you to throw it out there
they'll show me you're gonna whale tail
for me it's a orange thong that's Dragon
Ball Z underwear Beyond these dude I'm
not kidding when I say I wear them every
day
that print is crazy yeah I know I don't
[__] around
like I rocked the ones that have
dinosaurs on them those look like you
[__] around
let's look like you're putting on a show
that's true that is true yeah it's funny
because like I had this realization
sorry sorry what color are your uh what
are you wearing what kind of underwear
first of all
um
just boxer briefs it's so funny you pull
up your [__] you got a g-string yeah
yeah
and you know oh damn trendy yeah
it's a little bit tight and the butt
crack but it's good
no I'm just just black
black uh
Tom Klein
lulus Lulu really they make insane
boxers yeah see that's what I I like me
undies because I like the texture and
you know the micro modal Fabric and all
that [__] no but I actually do like we
started doing ads for them it's funny
because like when I was younger and I
like dreamed about having a podcast I
would see like the ones that I would
listen to all had me on these ads
because they were like one of the first
ones to like do Punk really Embrace
podcast marketing so you heard them on
every single podcast so they were like a
meme it was like if you listen to a
podcast you know you're gonna get at me
on these ad probably so the dream was as
like a budding you know podcaster maybe
one day we could get a meandies hat that
would be incredible like Sam and I used
to juggle that all the time yeah
and then when we finally started getting
them which by the way dream come true
it was amazing moment in my life and we
got the first meandies at
and I called it was like one of the
first advertisers we got right yeah it
was and I called Sam and I was like dude
our dream has come true well my dream we
got it yeah I got it yeah sorry I did it
without you but I got it yeah and then
they started selling just sending
sending undies yeah you know like every
week I get another pair of these [__]
yeah just started wearing them because
they're nice
and then I had this moment like two
weeks ago where I opened my drawer and
it's like literally just like all like
spaceship print underwear dinosaur
underwear and I'm like am I nine years
old yeah what am I doing if you are I
need adult man underwear like gray black
standard [__] every day I'm wearing
these dumbass prints
bro I'm gonna dance you in public yeah
exactly
yeah if I had a food court Mall
nice spaceships guy but when you pants
someone it's supposed to be you're
supposed to get them like naked right no
that's it'll be even funnier when you
have your [__] dinosaurs out there
kids dinosaur print just stand in front
of the Mongolian beef [__]
they're like you got dinosaur print
that's weird they just move your food
across the grill into the trash
Burger Kings that way speaking of I've
been eating like a idiot all week oh
yeah me too dude I've been living off
chicken fingers pizza oh yeah me too
same thing same thing I weighed myself
this morning
since I injured myself that's only four
weeks four weeks
five pounds it happened so fast for you
oh my God it's incredible
you need that espresso machine man I'm
telling you yeah you'll not you will not
eat I think that's an eating disorder
it is but I promise you the power of
that caffeine is stupid I know no I get
it I get it but I I can't like it comes
just don't need good
it's the bad too that comes with that
yeah but just don't like anxiety you
know yeah but just don't eat what have
you been eating
uh [__]
like
Instant Mac and Cheese yeah
chicken fingers
Merry Christmas everyone by the way I
know it's February but Merry Christmas
merry Merry Christmas yeah
um yeah just been eating [__]
yeah why
I don't know dude I I just don't want to
[__] do anything this week yeah I
want to cook yeah I'm rebelling against
the system it's cool it's because it's
cold yeah that's why yeah I don't want
to do [__] yeah it's cold outside
like it just seems like everything
nobody it's like work stops yeah not not
really in our industry I feel like this
is the busiest time it's 100 but
everyone else is like [__] there's this
holiday parties every single night
people are checked out they're worried
about Christmas gifts yep and just
getting [__] up yep what's favorite
everyone else so we've done that already
but yeah sorry yes yeah I'm speaking as
if Christmas was in February yes yeah
which today it is
so
this episode was definitely not filmed
in advance yeah for sure we didn't we
didn't Bank this one oh no this is live
what's been going on with February is a
crazy month yeah that's so crazy like
how many days are in this sucker a lot I
came out it was like less than every
other month I can't believe Jordan
Peterson got caught getting head in the
movie theater
oh yeah what rules
who says a grown man can get his big old
meat sticks slurped on in the movie
theater
oh nothing clever
sir you can't you can't do that what
rules what oh what rules
what is man if not getting head in a
movie theater
so you can't get head in a movie well
what is hat yeah why not
you're making many assumptions when you
when you act when you tell me I can't do
something like that
turn beers and getting head at all
assume I'm getting head I could be
giving her head
with my penis
all right Jordan
I see your logic
okay I like it I like it Jordan yeah
yeah J
jbp getting head is a crazy image yeah I
don't like that thought this [__]
skeletor-ass body oh man
[Laughter]
that guy almost sounds so crazy if he's
ever busted in that I don't think his
body could handle it I think he'd
explode
you think you think a dude like that
I mean
[__]
I think he has sex yeah he probably does
yeah okay has sex yeah he has sex yeah
yeah I don't think he's yeah
I don't know if anyone
at this point is like oh yeah yeah
it's like a necessity yeah yeah it's a
biological function yeah yeah yeah man I
mean here here he looks you know if he
didn't hear his voice you might think
this is a
this is a handsome old man yeah
it's it's too bad he got that voice
imagine if he had some deep
you know just crazy
you know most interest interesting man
in the world voice it'd be different
yeah yeah if he was British yeah well
who says I can't get hit in a movie
theater
yeah Mr Peterson you can't
I think you can't stand it that I've got
ahead in the movie theater I think
that's what has gone on here
I think you're quite perturbed that I've
received a dome in the theater
what movies are you watching about time
minions yeah
and we tweeted about teenagers whatever
some wants to go who did
he had a tweet and he said it's getting
so hard to find
I saw that I [__] saw that all the
replies are like FBI this guy right here
I think I mean he was like he was saying
like elon's doing a good job at
protecting children but it's like how do
you know that it's getting yeah hard to
find unless you're just can't find
anything anymore yeah what the [__]
oh God
and the smiley face like everything
about this tweet is like it rip it's
getting impossible to find
I don't know I'm turning into like
Kermit or something yeah yeah that's
close
it's close man yeah of course oh nice of
course he had to lean into it that's
good
uh we're looking at an image of Jordan
Peterson fisting Kermit the Frog
he's got his [__] He's elbow deep and
Kermit they're locked eyes right now
Mr Peterson
[Laughter]
I never thought we'd be this close
well neither did I